remember being sat by myself a lot
eating lunch alone
becoming more and more withdrawn
lizzy was only 12 years old when her
mental health deteriorated
the struggle with food i always say was
born out of my trouble with anxiety
because
i felt so out of control with everything
in my life and i can remember
making almost like lists in my head of
what i'd been eating that day and at one
point it was just that was the only
thing that gave me that sense of
security
she developed anorexia as a way of
coping with her anxiety and depression
by 15 her weight loss became so serious
lizzie was admitted to a psychiatric
unit for 10 weeks of life-saving
treatments
it was walking into hospital and seeing
other patients there and hearing the
alarms and seeing the locks on the doors
so for a 15 year old in a psychiatric
unit of a hospital that must be
terrifying
yeah it was i was like wow i must be
really sick to be here i remember
another patient there who had cuts all
down their arm
and there'd be alarms going off
where people had to be you know
withheld i called my parents and i
remember just crying to them please come
and get me i cannot stay here and
and that was just because the chaos
around me
more young people are being referred to
mental health services than ever before
in our service since 2019 we've seen an
increase in 140 percent the rate of
referrals in
dr dorothy newton and consultants in
eating disorders tell me social media
pressures around body image are helping
to drive the surge
i think that in many cases where a young
person develops an eating disorder it is
often multifactorial
but we have absolutely seen many young
people who are
developing eating disorders who feel
that they have been influenced
by online content and that has led to
for example anxiety about their body
shape
the pandemic has had a devastating
impact on young lives
adding to the pressure on already
stretched mental health services
are you confident mental health services
will be able to cope with this spike in
demand i think we'll cope we may have to
work differently but it's it's as busy
as it's been and it's as busy as i've
known in my career there is note that we
are in a different position to where we
were nationally about three years ago
numbers are up they're up across all age
groups and in all types of presentations
lizzie is now studying to be a doctor
one day
she hopes to use her own experiences
with other young people who need help
ashish joshi sky news west london